This world title is unique just because we're in a bubble,...
...we're in a situation where the whole year has just been unknown.
It's just been, as an athlete, uncertain.
We don't know what's going on.
So, to be able to have this opportunity to come here,...
...to be able to compete regardless of whether or not there are fans,...
...it just means a lot to the athletes.
It gives us something to work for, something to look forward to,...
...something just to strive for.
So, I think we're all really happy and lucky to be in this position...
...that we can compete at a competition.
And that being said, this competition was just different.
As an athlete, we love to have people watching.
We love to have people supporting.
So, it's strange to not have that.
I definitely think that the energy from the audience felt lacking...
...and of course they weren't there.
But still, again, returning back to what I was saying,...
...just lucky to be here and it's just awesome to have this opportunity.
Today, I just wanted to remind myself to be present...
...and be happy in this moment and just be calm.
I think that the short program was, I was a little bit frantic...
...and that was partially a result of just not having a lot of competitions this season...
...especially international competitions.
So, the nerves got the better of me.
But this time around, I just felt a lot more calm, a lot more present.
And that helped me perform a lot better...
...so hopefully I can learn from that and keep doing that in the future.